Партнери по НАТО тривалий час критикували Німеччину за недостатні витрати на збройні сили.
Але після початку війни Росії проти України канцлер ФРН Олаф Шольц оголосив
про безпрецедентне збільшення видатків на оборону. А саме 100 мільярдів євро
на швидке зміцнення військ - а далі суттєво збільшені витрати на оборону щороку.
Таким чином, Бундесвер, який вже давно скаржиться на хронічний брак інвестицій,
зможе закупити нове озброєння і модернізуватися.
Ці американські літаки посідають перше місце у списку майбутніх покупок Бундесверу.
F-35 можуть нести всі типи озброєнь - їхня конструкція та покриття
ускладнюють виявлення радарами. Оскільки нинішній парк винищувачів Німеччини
значною мірою застарів, оновлення назріло давно.
F35 - найсучасніший бойовий літак у світі, і багато наших партнерів, особливо тут, у Європі,
теж обрали цей літак.
Разом з нашими партнерами по Альянсу ми зміцнюватимемо нашу здатність
забезпечувати безпеку повітряного простору НАТО, надійно стримувати
і, в разі потреби, ефективно захищатися.
Угода знаменує собою зміну політики: замість того, щоб, як досі, займатися власними проєктами
розвитку озброєнь, Бундесвер купуватиме те, що вже є на ринку.
Дехто критикує, що це посилить залежність Німеччини від США.
Однак війна в Україні різко посилила питання якнайшвидшої військової модернізації.
Щодо протиповітряної оборони, то збройні сили Німеччини тепер розглядають можливість
придбати ізраїльську протиракетну систему. Вона називається Arrow 3
і доповнює так званий "Залізний купол" для захисту самого Ізраїлю від ракет.
Система здатна збивати балістичні ракети далекого радіусу дії та буде достатньо потужною,
щоб захистити країни Східної Європи.
Бундесверу також потрібні нові важкі транспортні гелікоптери для заміни старих
гелікоптерів Сікорського, розроблених ще у 1960-х роках.
Загалом список того, що необхідно Бундесверу, дуже довгий. Від кораблів і танків
до радіообладнання та боєприпасів. На те, щоб усунути відставання німецького війська,
спричинене десятиліттями хронічного недофінансування, швидше за все підуть роки.
Збройні сили і міністерство оборони ФРН офіційно створили лише через десять років
після закінчення Другої світової війни. У 1955 році Федеративна Республіка Німеччина
також стала членом НАТО. Але участь у бойових операціях за межами країни заборонялася.
Лише через майже 40 років солдатам Бундесверу дозволити
брати участь у міжнародних військових операціях.
На момент возз’єднання Німеччини у 1990 році загальна чисельність Бундесверу
та Національної народної армії НДР разом складала майже 600 тисяч осіб.
Об’єднувати два війська не стали. Армію колишньої НДР фактично розформували,
лише незначна частина офіцерів зі Східної Німеччини продовжила службу далі.
Поступово після завершення "холодної війни" Бундесвер суттєво скоротили,
і станом на кінець минулого року загальна чисельність німецької армії складала
183 з половиною тисячі осіб. З них понад 26 тисяч жінок.
Згідно з планами міноборони ФРН, чисельність армії має збільшитися
до 203 тисяч до 2025 року. Втім, зважаючи, як кажуть у Німеччині,
на "український шок", це може статися й раніше.
Ми всі повинні підготуватися до того, що ми маємо сусіда, який нині готовий
застосувати насилля для відстоювання своїх інтересів. І тому ми маємо разом
стати сильними, щоб цього не сталося.
У 2011 році німецьку армію повністю перевели на контрактну основу.
Цьому передувало поступове скорочення строку загального військового обов’язку.
У 60-ті німці служили півтора року, потім 15 місяців, 12, 10, 9 і так дійшли до пів року.
Перед скасуванням призову Бундесвер фактично вже був професійною армією.
Частка призовників складала лише 15 відсотків, решта - професійні військові
та ще невелика частка тих, хто залишилися на понадстрокову службу.
До закордонних місій Бундесверу призовників не залучають,
відправляють лише професіоналів. Щоправда, останніми роками
залучення нових солдатів у Бундесвер, попри масштабні рекламні кампанії, пробуксовувало.
Чимало німецьких політиків нині виступають за повернення до загальної військової повинності
і скасування призову вважають помилкою. Раніше приводом до гострої дискусії
була проблема з неонацистами, яких виявили в елітному підрозділі Бундесверу.
Деякі німецькі політики досі переконані, що правий екстремізм активніше
розвивається у професійній армії, ніж в армії за призовом.
Нині ж після початку російської агресії в Україні ідея повернення призову
в Бундесвер знову ожила. Втім, на думку уповноваженої Бундестагу
у справах німецьких військовослужбовців, "український шок" сам по собі
призведе до того, що більше молодих громадян ФРН захочуть служити в армії.